alors vous allez trouver ça un peu
bizarre mais il y a quelqu'un qui vient
d'atterrir là en plein milieu de la cour
de l'Assemblée nationale et c'est pas
n'importe qui c'est Thomas Pesquet on va
aller lui poser quelques questions
Thomas Pesquet si euh vous avez pris
beaucoup de photos depuis l'espace
est-ce que vous avez pris l'Assemblée
nationale depuis l'espace souvent vous
avez alors oui je l'ai prise j'ai pris
Paris en fait surtout depuis l'espace tu
sais le le périmètre d'une photo c'est à
peu près 15 km sur 20 km de la station
spatiale donc on voit Paris on voit du
détail on voit l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai pas centré la photo sur l'Assemblée
nationale cela vous la prochaine fois
il y a le brune pivée la votre question
bête aussi c'est avec quel député vous
accepteriez de partir 9 mois en mission
sans pouvoir revenir
vous voulez pas vous présenter un
élection législative
donc la première des choses c'est pour
bien planter le décor Thomas Pesquet
comment le spatial a un impact en fait
dans la vie de tout le monde comment
pour monsieur madame tout le monde
comment ils peuvent se rendre compte de
l'impact que le spatial a pour eux ouais
mais c'est vrai que parfois on se dit
c'est assez virtuel mais en fait ça
n'est pas du tout on sert tous les jours
des technologies spatiales il y a des
choses évidentes on connaît la météo
notre seule manière d'avoir la météo
c'est de la regarder depuis l'espace les
télécommunications la navigation par
satellite aujourd'hui tout le monde en
son smartphone en permanence utilise des
flottes de satellites qu'on soupçonne
même pas donc il y a vraiment des choses
qui sont très directes très faciles à
comprendre il y a évidemment toutes les
améliorations technologiques qui
découlent dans la société du fait que
c'est des choses difficiles d'envoyer
des choses dans l'espace et qu'il faut
innover qu'il faut être plus performant
avoir des meilleurs métaux des choses
comme ça ensuite ça passe dans
l'aviation dans la voiture dans tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer après il y a quelque
chose d'un petit peu plus lointain qui
est quand même important qui est le côté
recherche en fait qu'on fait dans la
station spatiale c'est essayer d'avoir
des découvertes sur qu'on peut pas faire
sur Terre en médecine en physiologie en
sciences des matériaux en chimie des
choses comme ça et puis vraiment le
dernier c'est la partie la plus long
terme c'est pourquoi on envoie des sons
un peu plus loin pour comprendre notre
univers comment tout ça s'est formé d'où
on vient où on va ces questions un peu
plus fondamentales mais qui sont
importantes si aujourd'hui on connaît
plus notre place dans l'univers qu'il y
a 50 ans et a fort sur évidemment qu'il
y a 2000 ans c'est parce qu'on a pris ce
recul et qu'on s'est donné les moyens
d'aller voir un peu plus loin du coup
comme justement c'est quoi le lien en
fait entre l'Assemblée nationale et le
spatial parce que c'est pas forcément
évident de premier abord c'est quoi le
lien entre les
alors l'Assemblée nationale c'est
toujours intéressé à la technologie aux
sciences et cela guide nos choix et nos
interventions et parfois nos votes
puisque nous votons un certain nombre de
budgets qui concernent directement
l'activité spatiale française donc il
est important que nos choix soient
éclairés nous avons un office des choix
technologiques qui est bicaméral et qui
existent depuis 40 ans et nous allons
fêter son anniversaire au mois de
juillet et c'est très important que les
parlementaires donc s'impliquent après
moi j'ai souhaité ouvrir l'Assemblée
nationale le plus largement possible et
le plus largement possible aux citoyen
et à son époque finalement et avec la
célébration des 50 ans du programme
Ariane il m'a paru intéressant
partenariat avec le CNES l'agence
spatiale de pouvoir célébrer cet
anniversaire dignement au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale coeur de notre vie
démocratique donc nous avons exposé
un certain nombre alors une maquette
Ariane un petit robot qui va sur Mars et
puis peut-être un module lunaire et puis
nous avons organisé cette conférence ce
soir et je suis ravie de voir que il y a
beaucoup de citoyens qui viennent y
participer et puis que nous avons des
invités prestigieux qui viennent ce qui
montre aussi que l'Assemblée nationale
est un lieu où il se passe des choses
loin du tumulte parfois de ce qui peut
se passer dans l'hémicycle et je
rebondis Thomas parce que je vous
poserai la même question juste après
aujourd'hui parmi les acteurs du spatial
il y a beaucoup d'acteurs alors du
public du privé on pense à Space X par
exemple comment la France elle trouve sa
place et le programme français trouve sa
place au milieu de tout ça
il est très important que la France soit
souveraine quelle est un accès à
l'espace et que la France et l'Europe
est un accès autonome à l'espace
indépendant parce qu'il y va aujourd'hui
comme Thomas Pesquet le disait de toutes
nos communications de notre capacité à
voir le monde à analyser le climat
communiquer et tant d'autres choses et
donc il est important d'avoir cette
souveraineté et donc la France et
l'Europe singulièrement doivent pouvoir
continuer à être des acteurs majeurs
nous avons aussi la chance d'avoir des
territoires d'outre-mer et la Guyane qui
nous permet de pouvoir avoir une base de
lancement ce qui n'est pas non plus
l'apanage de l'ensemble des autres pays
et donc cette spécificité c'est à tout
que nous avons combiné avec une vraie
volonté de souveraineté dans le domaine
spatial doivent être encouragés
réaffirmés et je crois que c'est ce que
aujourd'hui aussi la représentation
nationale
doit pouvoir dire à l'ensemble des
acteurs du monde spatial nous sommes
avec vous nous sommes derrière vous
parce que nous croyons dans la
souveraineté de la France et l'Europe
dans ce domaine là
même question même question donc très
bien non mais je pense qu'il faut
effectivement c'est important de
rappeler que le domaine spatial ça a
toujours été un endroit où les volontés
en fait des états driver les programmes
en bon français poussaient les
programmes il faut pas tomber dans le
mirage du privé je pense que ce que fait
Space X c'est fantastique mais en tant
que fournisseur de services à la NASA il
faut savoir que c'est des milliards de
contrats de la NASA qui a demandé à
SpaceX de développer des moyens d'accès
à l'ISF des services réguliers de de
cargo donc pour des masses quelques
tonnes par véhicule qui arrive à l'ISS
c'est essentiellement là dessus que se
repose le développement de de SpaceX
alors évidemment il y a de l'argent
privé dedans mais c'est quand même une
grosse majorité de de budget étatique
c'est aujourd'hui la NASA qui décide des
destinations et ensuite les entreprises
privées sont là pour répondre à des
demandes de réalisation technologique
qui font très très bien excellent bien
au sein on est bien d'accord et par
contre c'est pas Elon Musk qui décide
aujourd'hui des destinations
d'exploration qu'on va faire par exemple
dans les années qui viennent je pense
que la France et l'Europe sont
exactement dans cette logique là il faut
comme nous rappeler la Présidente il
faut être assis à cette à cette table de
négociation on voit bien qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup d'acteurs mais de chinois
indiens d'autres encore dans le secteur
spatial aujourd'hui on peut pas se
permettre de pas être à cette pas être à
cette table là le coup d'y participer il
existe évidemment c'est pas des choses
qui sont gratuites mais le coût de pas y
participer qu'on paierait en conséquence
dans quelques années qu'elle soit
technologique qu'elle soit
qu'elle soit sur du leadership et du
soft power mais il serait beaucoup plus
élevé ils sont justement d'un point pour
parler de climat vous vous avez vu les
les changements climatiques depuis
là-haut
le c'est préoccupations là maintenant
elles sont au cœur du programme spatial
comment ça comment ça rentre en compte
oui je pense qu'elles le sont en fait
alors c'est pas le la panache premier
des astronautes vraiment nous on utilise
la station comme la recherche en
impesanteur l'observation de la Terre on
a des flottes de satellites pour ça
encore une fois que ce soit au niveau
national au niveau de l'agence spatiale
au niveau de l'Union européenne
moi ce que j'ai fait c'est d'apporter
mon regard en fait en regard assez
humain mais on a aussi un regard qui est
très scientifique
en sous forme de données en fait
répétitives sont tenus tous les jours
par les satellites comme du programme
Copernicus
l'observation de la Terre ça a toujours
été parmi les plus gros programmes des
agences spatiales parce que c'est de
l'espace qu'on peut se rendre compte du
changement climatique c'est de l'espace
qu'on peut à l'échelle d'une planète à
l'échelle d'un océan comme l'océan
Pacifique détecter des variations de
température infime détecter des
tendances détecter des choses comme ça
la fonte des glaces la teneur en CO2 de
l'atmosphère donc je pense que les
agences spatiales c'est un peu les
championnes de du de la lutte contre le
changement climatique en générant toutes
ces données en mettant à disposition
gratuitement c'est important de le
rappeler des thérapies de données à tous
les scientifiques d'Europe et du monde
qui leur permet à eux et bien de
conclure et puis de d'amorcer le combat
contre le changement climatique
avec plaisir merci à vous